[Music]
there are conversations that will
intensify conflict or the potential
thereof and there are conversations who
will intensify understanding potentially
even resolution conversations that are
sure to polarize in which for everything
you say I come back with what I have to
say without ever taking into account
what you just said do you know what
happens when people disagree they
literally have the capacity to listen to
10 seconds of what the other side has to
say 10 seconds that's three sentences
and by then they already are busy
creating their rebuttal they are no
longer listening they are just preparing
their return their retort when you have
that kind of conversation here is what
happens one is I am constantly just
going to come back at you I am not
integrating what I heard from you and it
doesn't influence anything of what I'm
saying so basically you're saying the
same thing over and over again and I'm
saying the same thing over and over
again and those two never meet and the
more I say ex the more I make you say
why it's like you're going I'm going to
it's me who is reinforcing you saying
the fundamental thing with which you
disagree with I come with expectations
of what I think you think or may say or
may want all relationships are colored
with expectations about myself and about
the other my expectations influence that
which I then see or hear it is a filter
as well as my mood is a filter we in
communication have the ability to set
the other people up because we will draw
from them the very things which we
expect from them even if when it's the
opposite of what we really want we
create the others in relationships and
in communication it isn't just that
they are and that's who we are that is
one of the most important things to
understand about relationships and
communication is how people actually
co-create each other in the context of a
relationship and why we are not the same
person with different people because
those people make part of who we are
when we are in conflictual relationships
we will often be prone to negative
attributions which is that when you
speak to me a certain way it's because
you have a bad temper or you have a
nasty personality when I speak to you in
a certain way it's because I had a lot
of traffic getting here this morning and
because I'm having a bad day you are a
bad person I have just bad circumstances
I essentialize you and I contextualize
me all of these things will intensify
conflict it's the opposite that will
create the potential for understanding
is my ability to take in what you say to
mull it over to include it in my
response so that I make you feel that
you matter that what you say makes a
difference that it enters me that you're
not just talking to the wind what is
lacking is the ability to see that
speaking is entirely dictated by the
quality of the listening that is
reflected back on us if I am talking to
someone who is on their phone I will be
expressed expressing myself and
experiencing the communication
completely different than if I am
speaking to someone who is looking at me
in the eyes who is shaking their head
who is says to me I get it
I understand not necessarily I agree so
when you listen to me the first thing I
need to know is that I have your
attention the second thing I need to
know is that maybe you can acknowledge
the validity of my point of view that
doesn't mean you agree with my point of
view but my point of view makes sense
and potentially you may even empathize
with my point of view you can understand
why I would think or feel or experience
things the way I do that reflecting back
acknowledging validating empathizing
that sequence is where the depth of
communication takes place because
ultimately if I speak to you and in the
end I leave feeling even more alone I'm
literally in an existential crisis there
is nothing worse than to be alone in the
presence of another
[Music]